cases continue to surge across our  country it's showing more negative  impacts on the job market  the government releasing some new  numbers for november today  employers across our country adding 245  thousand jobs last month  that is much lower than the nearly 640  thousand  added back in october the national  unemployment rate though  did drop slightly from 6.9 percent down  to 6.7 percent  president-elect joe biden is calling the  latest jobs report evidence of the worst  economic and jobs crisis in modern u.s  history  millions of people have lost their jobs  or had their hours slashed  they lost their health insurance or in  danger of losing their health insurance  if we act now now i mean now  we can begin to regain momentum meantime  senate majority leader mitch mcconnell  and house speaker nancy pelosi resuming  negotiations for an economic  relief bill